[Music]
what does it mean to live a life of
service these words are thrown about
pretty easily being a servant leader
being in the service industry but what
does it actually mean to live a life of
service there's one person who knows a
lot more about this than the rest of us
Maria Shriver has grown up in a family
completely devoted to service and she
and all of her siblings have also
devoted their lives to service so we
decided to go for a socially distant
walk together please excuse the noise
from the traffic in the wind this is a
bit of optimism test test okay I'm
recording so the thing that I thought I
wanted to talk to you that was service
yes what does it mean what does service
mean in the 21st century because I think
it's changed so I think that service can
be really small actions as a woman wrote
today that she african-american woman
wrote that she was scared of the police
so she sent out a Facebook message in
her neighborhood and invited the police
to her house for cookies and coffee to
talk to talk and to her to listen and I
thought to myself that's so big but in
her mind it was so small and I think
we're so focused on we have to change
the world we have to topple the Catholic
Church we have to defund the police as
opposed to these singular actions that
we can each take whether it's making a
placard and go standing in a black box
but has it always been that way like I
went from just living my life every day
to now I never have a revolution and
topple all the establishments first of
all the good thing is is that all the
establishments are an eater for for
without good news and the bad news right
the second question is well who's going
to do that right the third question is
all of us right each and every one of us
but I think we each have to pick a lane
we each have to find what is it right it
speaks to you because what speaks to you
is different than what speaks to me so
you can either educate yourself about
what's already being done and join in
that and be of service to something
that's already underway or do your act
like this woman did that's small but big
in your neighborhood because being of
service right actually ends up being of
service to you and I think that's the
biggest thing people go into service
thinking it's about the other yeah and
it really pays off to you yeah but the
thing that I think is interesting about
this modern day and I and it absolutely
is because of our ultra connected fast
media 24-hour news cycle that we seem to
go from so everybody was angry about you
know fixing something helping something
doing something you know everybody gave
money everybody did a challenge on
Instagram and then we forgot that thing
never got never got fixed or reformed
and I think the key is we can't forget
right right I was quoting my uncle the
other day on health care reform his
entire career yeah and it didn't even he
died before it was passed right my
mother her entire 88 years on the planet
on behalf of people with intellectual
disabilities in one way shape or form
staying the course what we seem to have
in this modern day and age right is
everybody screaming about one thing for
a short period of time and then yeah the
vast majority of that and the vast
majority then moves on to the next noisy
thing demanding change until the next
noisy thing and look I hope this is
different to hope the time we're living
it now is different but to your point to
be truly of service right it has to be
passionate first of all which means it
has to be personal you have to have some
sort of connection yeah to that thing
and you devote your life to it just like
just like a passionate job a passionate
career you don't just bounce from
industry to industry in this industry
you have passion for something I think
the challenge is in a
time where everything is immediate and
fleeting how do each of us dig in how do
each of us find a way to step back and
say am I still on my path
am I still involved in what I said I was
in and for some people especially I
think a lot of young people will say
like well I did this when I was 20 but
then I found that I was interested in
this when I was 30 and that's okay
everybody doesn't have to stay the
course of course
more than a more than a few months or
more than a year well more than a minute
right and I think what's important to
know also or to remember is that people
you know spend lifetimes and move the
needle like this and it's really up to
us to decide is that good enough you
know a lot of people are screaming now
oh my god nothing has changed in America
that's not true that's just not true
it may not have changed as quickly or as
rapidly or as deeply as people wanted it
to when Martin Luther King died
expressing his dream has that been
realized no not to the full extent but
people are still talking today about his
dream people have amended it the
question I think for each of us is we
still invoke it as a rallying they do
absolutely and I think the question for
each of us is do you have any vision at
all and what is your vision my vision I
always characterize my vision as the
open field because it works for me it
comes off of a Rumi Persian mystic poem
which is out beyond ideas of right doing
and wrong doing he wrote there's a field
I'll meet you there and I many years ago
wrote on to that out beyond ideas of
right doing and wrong doing out beyond
fear shame judgment and labels there's a
field I'll meet you there and that's my
vision for the country I live in that we
will get beyond skin color race labels
judgement
fear pain and we'll meet there that's my
vision you're raising there just
important which is the difference
between revolution and evolution right
which is both both accomplished change
and it seems now and I don't know if
this is a current thing that all the
change that people are demanding is
revolutionary which is sudden and it's
about overturning right versus evolution
which is obviously slower sometimes
frustratingly slow right but it's much
more stable as if there's a revolution
there's also almost always a counter
revolution there's almost always a group
of people that dig in because they feel
threatened and arguably revolutionary
change isn't necessarily stable yes
there has to be vision the whole idea is
not to simply stop something but to
start something not to end something but
to begin something not to break
something down but to build something
anew and that's the part that I think to
truly be of service you have to to
invoke dr. King again you have to know
the dream you have to know the thing
you're going towards so that you know
the revolutionary elements the tactics
the steps that you have to take to get
there
otherwise it's argue I mean I was gonna
say I don't want to argue with you but I
do love arguing with you pushing up
against you but I don't think that some
people they they get in and they don't
know the steps they get in because their
heart has been impacted they've been
moved by a story or someone's life or
someone else and they just get in I
don't think everybody knows every step
it's like starting a relationship you
don't know where it's gonna go but you
have the courage to get in but there are
people like Fidel Castro Che Guevara
there are people like Martin Luther King
there are people like eunice Kennedy
Shriver there are people like Robert
Kennedy but even like in Robert Kennedy
he evolved into his voice but you would
I would say that about every great
leader so I think it's sometimes you we
keep people saying if you don't know the
tactics if you don't have the vision if
you don't have the steps don't get it
yeah I think people put too much
pressure especially young people in this
day and age because they're constantly
being asked what's your vision what's
your purpose what's your what so that's
my chair do I no I'm not no I'm not no
you're not you're pushing Liz
I don't think I don't think you have to
have your own vision you can find the
vision that someone else has articulated
and you say that I'm interested in that
well what if you're not you don't have
maybe you're just interested in being a
part of the process that's like but but
there are many people who knew that
change was needed and when they heard
dr. King's vision they said that's the
thing I want to be a part of Oh when
when when they heard your uncle Jack's
inaugural they said that's what I've
been trying to say and this is what this
is why we need leaders because leaders
are able to capture in words and vision
the thing that we feel that we know
emotionally drives us but I struggle to
put into words we have to have a vision
it doesn't have to be uniquely ours
right the question I'm trying to raise
is is what is it that gives our lives
meaning and how do we commit ourselves
to a life of service and if we truly
want to see systemic change in any in
any part of our society right yeah what
is the way that each individual can
contribute some will do it at a big
level at a policy level and some will do
two at a small level at home like the
story you told before of the
african-american woman who invited
police over to her house for tea because
she was afraid of police
and she chose to be of service by doing
the thing that she's asking others to do
to listen right which is which is when
she confronted her own fear right so how
do we create systemic change that
requires a long time of pushing reaping
reimagining compromises pushing again so
you know I think that's one thing how do
we be of service it's to look outside of
ourselves find something that makes us
mad as hell
or that diggnation button and there are
plenty of things there and say I want to
be part of that because that angers me
that is unjust to me I was having a
conversation this week with Lisa Leslie
the you know most decorated female
basketball player of all time and she
wrote this really incredible letter
called dear America and in our
conversation she said you know I
I try to say to people as this if you're
in a family and you have a brother or a
sister that's constantly being abused
your parents don't give that kid the
same educational opportunities as the
two or three other kids if that kid gets
only hand-me-down clothes if that kids
and she went through a litany of things
she goes that's what the black community
feels and we are a family so think about
it like that which I thought was so
beautifully articulated and she said my
husband was a graduate of the Air Force
Academy fought in two wars and when he
walks into a room in his uniform people
give him so much respect and adoration
and they thank him for his service when
he walks in a room with his sweatshirt
on and his flip-flops people recoil
they're scared so how do we get to a
place where when people walk in the room
right and that's gonna take systemic
change that's gonna take education
that's gonna take unlearning that's
gonna take pushing into your
uncomfortable self I mean so I think in
all of these things some things will
topple much quicker I try to say to my
children let's find it area that you
feel passionate about find an area that
speaks to you that you think you can
make a difference in that you want to
make a difference in and that brings you
joy and passion and purpose in making a
difference in yeah I think the challenge
to each of us is how are we here how are
we spending our time here and are we
being of service to something that
species does so that goes back to the
idea of what does it mean to serve what
does it mean to live a life of service
and you know if we look at these two
young generations
you have the Millennials and then this
newest generation Gen Z we talked about
this at our table lesson and they're
very different and Millennials as a
generation of course not all of them but
they were they were labeled slacktivism
which is everything was to drive a
conversation and you would tweet your
discontent and you would do all the
challenges and all the things on
Instagram that you were crying to do and
then two months later you're on to the
next or you felt that you were doing
good because you bought a pair of shoes
that that company gave a pair of shoes
you know to someone who needed them yeah
and and it made you feel good because
you were quote-unquote
in service this this younger generation
that's Jen's II what I love about them
is they're an activist generation
yeah they don't tweet their discontent
they organize rallies they strike from
school whatever it is they're trying to
do there there are much more engaged and
show up they seem to be willing to
sacrifice something more than 140
characters well I have kids in both and
I think that's a judgment in
generalization of course and they would
say like you baby boomers you left us
this mess I'm a Boomer I would concur
and so yet I think we did a lot to push
the envelope as boomers yeah and
continue by the way so let me ask a
question on does service require
sacrifice I think everything requires
choice and sacrifice depends how you
define sacrifice is it because if you're
enjoying it no so you know those who
volunteer to be in the military they're
willing to make the ultimate sacrifice
that's what they call putting your life
they're putting their lives on the line
for something they believe in the
greater good there are people who work
in for impact organizations for
charities who have sacrificed income
because they you know they don't get
paid a lot of money there are people who
are out protesting they've sacrificed
potentially their health in this day and
age taking time away from family or work
or whatever it is can you can you be of
service if all you do is send a little
bit of money and do it and do an
Instagram challenge is that service well
once again I think you're asking me to
comment on those people and I'm trying
to understand I know no I'm not looking
for shame I'm genuinely trying to
understand if someone says I want to
live a life of service right so if
you're a nun and you want to live a life
of service that means you're gonna take
a vow of poverty chastity and you're
gonna live in community so for somebody
who is loves that
believes in that it's not a sacrifice
it's a joy to me that would be a
sacrifice right but it's considered a
sacrifice you're going against a human
instinct but it depends on the person if
you talk to people mmm nuns who have
been in it for 40 years or 50 years when
I was in India I talked to all these
young women who had joined mother
teresa's mothers of Calcutta young girls
it's like it's a joy it's a calling it's
not a sacrifice right so I think it's
really so individual I think if you look
at your service as a hardship what
you're losing all these sort of stuff
then you're not in the right place I
concur no I agree with that but that's
different though you're not blind to the
sacrifice the difference is you feel the
sacrifice is worth it yes let's climb to
hell since we're talking about sacrifice
right there's a stulen and there's this
gut feeling that I have okay that
service comes with some sort of
sacrifice or struggle that there's no
there's no life come with that but I
guess what I'm getting at is if we want
to effect change that there is no easy
solution and if we want to affect change
we have to give up something time energy
correct in order to have the feeling
that I'm contributing to change okay you
have to know your thing right do you
think a woman who for example is
devoting her life to motherhood is being
of service 100 percent okay a hundred
percent yes so many women and did that
come with sacrifice based on your
definition no what no that's not true so
sacrifice only if she wanted to be a
lawyer what she really wanted to do was
be a lawyer and she decided to settle
and just be a mom if somebody wants to
build a huge company and make tons of
money and as a result of that choice
because we're talking about making
choices okay they have weak
relationships with their children and
when the children become adults feel
they don't have they don't have a deep
relationship a deep level is with that
parent yes now in our modern day and age
would say that person sacrificed their
family
to make to make money or fame or
whatever the thing is right right right
so that person is lying on their
deathbed with no one around them yeah
there can be no regret you'd have to
talk to them although I hear all the
time when I read nurses who write about
regrets of the dying that's always
number one and so people when they slow
down enough they look at their choices
differently so now this goes back to the
idea of service which is so I'm gonna
I'm gonna title and write which is try
which is service has to benefit another
so the people who choose to sacrifice
quote-unquote for themselves fame and
fortune right did you said from these
nurses reports that the big regrets we
in other words that wasn't worth it they
discover on their deathbed or regret
about it they have a regret about it yes
but people who live a life of service
meaning that the sacrifices they made
you sacrifice I sacrifice my interests I
chose to give up the things that would
directly benefit me in order to benefit
others that is what it means to live a
life of service the path I chose versus
I chose to sacrifice the lives and
health and whatever of others so that I
may benefit my children wanted to love
me and be close to me but I was too busy
that's such an individual thing I would
think the question but what everybody I
notice the path they choose I cannot I
cannot abide okay they don't hold uh but
that we can say that someone has lived a
life of service I did if all the benefit
went to them I didn't say that you
didn't say that that's what I'm trying
to do I'm trying to say I have lived a
life of service when I sacrificed my
interests for the good of others or the
greater good yes that person may be
sitting there going I tried to do all
this for you
generally I'm not judging that person
but it's the person who built the
company and didn't go to the little
leagues who didn't show up as a father
will say gosh I did all this for you for
my kids and my wife and my family except
the thing they didn't do unlike that
wonderful woman who talked to the police
was sit down with the family and
listen Yan talk yes and I think that was
an assumption that was made yes and I
think that's changing I think you know I
don't see men or women at that matter I
think much more conscious today of the
choices the ramification the collateral
damage of our choices in a way that I
think when I was growing up was not part
of the national conversation which
brings me back to how these things have
raised men are very different today in
your generation than in mind then in my
father's generation in the sense that
everything how they look at the choices
they're aware of the trade-offs before
it was like that was how a man was
supposed to be right
a woman was supposed to be this way and
because boomers pushed up and said I
want to be more fully seen more fully
valued women right there were choices
that came with that they can you have it
all question right men by saying I can
be more evolved I can be sensitive
I can cry no one told me that so that is
HUGE and that's in my lifetime you know
time conclusion that I'm drawing from
all of this are you
of course please oh I've never I've
never talked to you or not learning
something every time I interact with you
I'm just that little bit wiser the the
two things that I'm really appreciating
from this conversation is this idea of
sacrifice which I still have to unwrap
if i if I'm honest but I do like the
idea of choices and that that the
sacrifice is really only a sacrifice
from from the viewer from the viewing
gallery because for those who are in it
it feels worth it and so it doesn't
quote-unquote feel like a sacrifice it's
like doing a job that you love right you
work with passion you work late hours or
you may turn down a better paying job
and it's fine it's totally worth it
you love the thing you're doing correct
and so I really appreciate this idea
that we get to choose how we live our
lives and and and we have to remember
that our choices are our own and if it
feels like a sacrifice if it feels like
this doesn't feel worth it then maybe
change paths so life becomes this this
searching or dusting looking for my path
the thing that I think makes being a
human being so much fun it's kind of
like it's kind of like you know you sort
of get a sense that God has a sense of
humor that all of the food that tastes
so good is so bad for us and all the
food that's so good for us yeah it's so
bland and now you have to go choose yeah
and and it seems that life has a similar
paradox which is all of the things that
that take away from serving some higher
calling living at quote unquote life of
service it's Patrick can I answer the
phone worse I sweetheart I'm walking
with Simon up a hill for his podcast and
he's arguing with me but I'm taking this
call to give me some reprieve we're up
we just walked by you know
Tigers kept walking up and then come
down or far up yeah but we're coming
down how are you baby are you on your
way home oh oh okay great I'll be home
in a little bit then okay sweetheart
I'll go on a bike ride with you after
okay
okay so what we're saying is I always
make a choice no matter what I'm doing
to pick up the phone when one of my
children call no I love it it's one of
the things I love about you oh I know
how devoted to your family are it makes
me smile when you choose your child of
our conversation with me trust me I I
like that okay no no I I sit here with a
smile on my face growing here's a woman
with values this is one of the reasons I
like her you know and it comes from a
desire to make sure and I feel blessed
with my parents but it comes from a
desire to make sure that
these four people feel like they're a
priority with a capital P yeah and that
nothing else is as important as them
yeah and they will argue with me or they
say you run around your chicken with
your head cut off why don't you stop
what are you doing why do you do that
you're making all these sacrifices to
your health
you could be out finding a boyfriend so
in their eyes I'm sacrificing the life
that I could be living for the life I am
living as opposed to recognizing that
has it made the choice and this is the
and you love the pathway and I love the
path so so so so the analogy I was
making was is it God has the sense of
humor you know all the things that are
good for us or blind and all things that
are bad for us is so tasty but it seems
like that living our life is very
similar which is all of the things like
making money power Fame all of the
selfish stuff is so addictive and once
you have some of it you want more of it
and yet the challenge in life is to live
a life of purpose means actually giving
some of that stuff up in order to do
good for others now you can also make
that stuff and do good for others but at
some point the there are sacrifices to
our personal lives to our personal
ambitions to our personal desires to our
personal Joy's that we do so willingly
so that others may gain we cannot live
entirely selfish lives that is not a
life of service well I think that's also
an unhappy life an unhappy life and you
and I both know people who've made that
choice and they there is a lot of
unhappiness right but I don't know at
the end of people's lives what is B well
there was a wonderful head audition by
an EMT and basically there's this belief
in the medical community living amongst
EMTs that you lie to people when they're
facing him into death he said you know
there's this used to be this belief that
if somebody clearly was gonna die then
his horrible car accident
they've lost too much blood and they
look up to the EMT and say am I gonna
make it you see this in combat you know
yeah and somebody would always say
you're gonna be fine
you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
fine there was this belief that we have
to reassure them with good news even
even if the news is bad and the CMT
tells the story of how he showed up I
think was a motorcycle accident and the
the woman was was not gonna survive and
she says am I gonna make it and he says
you're not he told her the truth and
apparently the result was incredible
which it was there was this this calm
resignation an acceptance that came over
her and this is what he started doing he
went on this journey where when he would
come across these cases though he would
of course fight tooth and nail to keep
them alive that he wouldn't lie to them
anymore and he found the pattern to be a
hundred percent consistent but they all
said please tell my family I love them
and it's really phenomenal and and what
was abundantly clear to everyone is we
want to live a life of value in the
lives of others we want to have been
valued in the lives of others not that
just we served ourselves but and you
think about it we no nobody wants on
their tombstone their last title on
their business card or whatever the last
balance was on their checking account we
we want on our tombstones the kind of
person we were two others beloved
beloved mother loyal father whatever it
is it's it's always the thing when we
want to be remembered by this is how
were we to others yes but I also feel
people come to these Forks in their Road
in very different ways and at different
times and I think it's it's usually
through suffering there's that word know
then not sacrifice through suffering
through a choice that went bad someone
who lied to you and you discover it
whatever it may be but through suffering
and out of that kind of waken a
different human being so it's not
sacrifice that's required for service
its suffering
I think sufferings baby that's required
for service and I don't think we talked
enough
well they sound crazy about the benefits
and how people when they're suffering
they think there is no other side so I
think the more people share their
stories of intense deep personal
darkness you know the dark night of the
soul the suffering and the other side of
that I think that's huge benefit to
other people and maybe the people who
struggle to find their purpose the
people who struggle to find their cause
have not yet suffered in a way that
would illuminate that path and I think
without the suffering this is what this
this is when people go from cause too
close too close to cause where they're
really entered for five minutes but
they're there searching searching
searching suffering but the searching
kindnesses and the searching and
alliteration here we are you and I both
love alliteration suffering and
sacrifice this is why we have movements
because no one of us can do it alone
it's a massive massive massive I talked
to you you were like where is Martin
Luther King where is the leader no I
still think there needs this I still
think we need that it's a massive
massive massive jigsaw puzzle but
somebody has to point to the picture on
the box right otherwise we're holding
pieces to puzzles that we don't know
where they go or what role they play
yeah well where they belong we there has
there has to be there has to be someone
on the ship saying go due north
otherwise how do we know where to set
the sail right
but the story ship is probably fraud of
course and we'll make mistakes and we'll
make navigational errors yeah but but
they still have to have a sense for the
forest for the trees
yeah yes otherwise because the rest of
us are in down in the rocks because
there is no straight path I think this
is the magical this is the magical
relationship between leaders and
followers which leaders are above the
trees saying that's the there's the
promised land I can see it I can see it
in my imagination it's right over there
and the road is a world which the vast
majority of people wake up inspired feel
safe wherever they are and in the day
beyond that what does that actually look
like how do you get to that place well I
think there are men
many many many many pieces to this very
complicated puzzle of which there are
there are social components there were
career components there are there are
government components and we need
soldiers and leaders in all those places
because we need change at a social level
we need change at a and all those
institutions that you listed in that
world
all those institutions the church and
the police and all of them require to
move towards is there something that
ties them all together for me it's it's
it's kind condition for me it's it's
about human relationships that that we
are tribal animals that need each other
that have to learn to work together and
the great irony is all the things that
we want in our lives selfishly are more
likely to happen when we commit to
helping other people get those same
things correct so in my fully my
imagined world when I look at health
disparities I imagine a health care
industry where everybody is able to be
seen able to pay for it able to access
it and I think that goes from education
the police system yeah that's the thread
for all these institutions and if each
of these institutions had that at their
base right and that adding in there
right that you're fully safe in a
relationship in a community in our
country that you don't have to worry
you're a black man or about walking down
the street if you're a woman I worry if
I walk down the street at night when I
was young I worried all the time I have
that in common
I thought maybe I'm not thinking I'm
gonna be pulled over and shot but I'm
thinking other things that are equally
detrimental to me as a young woman so I
think we all have to live it to live a
life without fear yeah I don't like
things written against I like things
that are written for so to live a life
where I feel safe yes and I mean I mean
yeah isn't that we only we don't wake up
in the morning feel safe as we go to
work and come home send our kids knowing
that our kids are safe on the way to
school and coming
that I got a hospital guys gun reform to
health care to black lives matter to
feminine everyone has the right to feel
safe but bingo and if we're all in
service to that it will be a good world
it'll be the world we imagined all of us
uniformly exactly yeah and so great
leadership is actually great
followership and and what I'm learning
is what followership means what
followership means is this is my path
right and there may be a leader on that
path who's helping direct me but this is
my path that I chose and we're all doing
different things that's important
they're all doing or doing this is what
your open field is my jigsaw puzzle yes
and my what I've always believed is that
each of us has a responsibility to speak
loudly about what our piece of the
puzzle is and to hold it up high above
our head so that others can see where
where our pieces join because only when
we work together
only when we share only when we share
information share lessons learned share
hardship so that others don't make the
same mistakes well the pieces come
together to actually form that world in
which every single one of us feels safe
yeah it takes millions of pieces of
puzzle and we need a language that
people can hear and we need leaders who
can point to the box so it feels like
brings us back to my god there's a lot
that needs to be done and there's so
much opportunity to do things that need
thank you for listening to me thank you
for letting me feel hurt it is a big
part of it huge so I would you know I
would follow you anywhere I don't have
anywhere to go
but what was that what's that well I
think you're the path that you're on in
the field that you're going to yes I
would I would follow you I would I would
follow you there thank you I I
envisioned you there you know with your
jigsaw puzzle on a pine table over there
with a beautiful woman sitting next to
you who likes to play jigsaw puzzles
with you I do like jigsaw puzzles okay
there you go
that's a good vision isn't it let's go
you don't have to feel you made a
sacrifice she's waiting for me in the
field she is absolutely
that's what I think everyday for myself
actually I have a vision in my field you
know I have a very clear vision in my
field that was a such a good
conversation that thank you the big
thing that I learned from Maria is that
a life of service requires struggle and
it's the struggle that brings us
together with each other thanks for
listening if you'd like to hear more
episodes but without the ambient sounds
please subscribe to a bit of optimism
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself and
take care of others